Tuyet điểm chuyển giao sang nằm ở hàng in không tra mi sấu,
như thành phố lớn trên đi dời đáng huy mở,
mọi thung hẹn quy mô cơ sự kẹn lễ hội,
đồng thời trên khai an ninh nghiêm gặp,
gió nhiều sự kẹn gặn đây chứ thành tâm điểm tấn công.
Bạn nghĩ thành phố điều giang vẫn tổ chứ đếm nợ tại quản trường thời đại,
sau đã khu vực nè trong tình trạng an ninh cao đầu,
với lực lượng cảnh sát anh cường.
Ở chào ông, chính quyền parui đáng huy mùi hoài nhà chuyên thống trên lộ trong lý dây,
trong khi bác liền tăng cường giang chẳng và kìm sốt quan tổng rần đúng.
Tại ốc chuyên lia chính quyền băng niêu sau quên,
huy các sự kiện tâm số khu vực nộ nội sau những dịt bị nạn ninh đáng hồng hại,
trong khi đáng huy dần xí rí bếp vào năm mời bị tâm thế lời bất em,
nơi và năng chật vật với những vết thường chiến tranh,
như ra điện và năng loại hoài đến nụ cầu cử bản mỗi ngày.
Con ở châu Á, cho kêu tức tụ khuy hoạt động đếm ngược tại khu xíu vui á,
đông thời sết cho khoal yên trở tự đủ thi, như vệnh pháp được tùng ra trong bối cảnh ăn ninh bằng cầu diện biến vức tà.